Es ist kein Beweis für die Unmöglichkeit des
Determinismus, aber es ist ein Beweis für die
Unmöglichkeit oder die hohe Unplausibilität
des physikalischen Determinismus, der
nur durch physische
Abenteuer bedingt ist, also beginne ich mit einigen
Definitionen, obwohl physische Ereignisse
oft als Ereignisse definiert werden, an
denen Kritiker beteiligt sind  Zugehörigkeit zu einer wahren
und vollständigen Physik oder einem Supervenient
ihres Arms ist dies keine sehr hilfreiche
Definition, da wir nicht viel
darüber wissen, wie eine zukünftige wahre und vollständige
Physik aussehen würde, aber es gibt
sicherlich eine Eigenschaft, die alle Ereignisse
mit der Zukunft haben  Physik
betroffen wäre, und das ist die
Eigenschaft, öffentlich zugängliche
Ereignisse zu sein, also werde ich ein physisches
Ereignis wie auf Ihrem Handzettel als ein Ereignis definieren, zu
dem keine Person privilegierten
Zugang durch Erfahrung hat, sollte ich hinzufügen und wenn
ich zeigen kann, dass das  Der kausale Abschluss
des Physischen ist bei dieser
Definition physikalischer Ereignisse
nicht plausibel, bei jeder anderen wird es sicherlich nicht plausibel sein.
c  Derzeit verfügbare Definition
werde ich ein physisches Ereignis einem
mentalen Ereignis gegenüberstellen, das als eines definiert wird, dem
die Person unterliegt, die es
notwendigerweise privilegiert hat,
indem sie es erlebt, und ich werde
ein reines mentales Ereignis als ein mentales
Ereignis definieren, das nicht beinhaltet  das
Eintreten eines physischen Ereignisses durch eine
Person, die privilegierten Zugang zu einem bestimmten
Ereignis hat, meine ich, dass er oder sie
notwendigerweise in einer besseren Position als jeder andere ist, um
zu wissen, dass es eintritt, egal auf welche
Weise andere herausfinden können, ob
es eintritt oder nicht  Die Versuchsperson kann
auch verwenden, aber die Versuchsperson hat eine
zusätzliche Möglichkeit, indem sie es unter
physischen Ereignissen erlebt, sind Gehirnereignisse. Jeder,
der lernt, wie man die entsprechenden
Geräte benutzt, kann
so viel über meine Gehirnereignisse herausfinden wie ich
oder wie jeder andere Wahrnehmungen wie
z  Dass ich einen Baum sehe, sind andererseits mentale Ereignisse,
denn wie auch immer
andere herausfinden können, ob
ich einen Baum sehe oder nicht, wie zum Beispiel das Beobachten
meiner  Verhalten und Studieren meines Gehirns, das ich
auch verwenden könnte. Ich könnte mir einen Film über
mein Verhalten ansehen und die Gehirnereignisse
genau so gut studieren wie jeder andere, aber ich
habe eine zusätzliche Möglichkeit, etwas über
meine Wahrnehmung zu erfahren, nämlich indem
ich tatsächlich wahrnehme, tatsächlich
sehe  Die Baumwahrnehmungen sind jedoch
nach meiner Definition keine reinen mentalen Ereignisse,
da das Sehen eines Baums mit sich bringt,
dass ein Baum vorhanden ist, und das ist ein physisches
Ereignis, aber
dass ich einen Baum zu sehen scheine, der ich bin, zu glauben, dass ich einen Baum sehe,
beinhaltet das nicht  Existenz des
Baumes und das ist ein reines mentales Ereignis.
Die Klasse der reinen mentalen Ereignisse umfasst
alle bewussten Ereignisse, bei denen ein Elternteil
Ereignisse dieser Art erlebt, dass
sie nur insoweit auftreten, als wir uns bewusst sind,
dass sie auftretende bewusste Ereignisse sind,
einschließlich Empfindungen wie Schmerzen  und
übelkeitsgefühle und
farbmuster in meinem gesichtsfeld dazu gehören auch
aktuelle gedanken die mir durch den kopf schossen
wie der heutige freitag wenn ich nicht in
einem bin  Ich bin mir bewusst, dass ich Schmerzen habe oder
denke, dass heute Freitag ist
und ich habe keine Schmerzen und der Gedanke kommt mir nicht in den
Sinn. Reine mentale Ereignisse
umfassen auch scheinbare Wahrnehmungen wie meine
scheinbare Wahrnehmung eines Baumes, scheinbares
Bewusstsein der eigenen Überzeugungen  und Wünsche
und auch scheinbares Gewahrsein von Wahrheiten der
Vernunft wie bewußt sein von
2:23 drei sind 69 wie ich darüber nachdenke auch
unter bewußten Ereignissen sind Absichten Mit
meiner Absicht meine ich, was ich versuche,
meinen Zweck zu erfüllen, den ich versuche  Absichten zu
erfüllen
sind kurzfristige Absichten
wie die Absicht, einen Arm zu bewegen, oder
nach einem Satz mittelfristige Absichten
wie zum Bahnhof gehen
oder zu Mittag essen, was ein Zweck ist,
den ich
über einen längeren Zeitraum zu erfüllen versuche  und auch langfristige
Absichten wie die Absicht, ein Buch zu schreiben
oder eine Karriere zu verfolgen, die ich versuche
, durch Aktionen zu verschiedenen
Zeiten über einen langen Zeitraum zu erfüllen, wenn
mein Körper eine Bewegung ausführt  eine Art,
die ich normalerweise absichtlich tue,
die aber diesmal einfach ein
unbeabsichtigter Reflex war, dann gab es keine
Absicht in dem, was ich in
Bezug auf Absichten tat, wie
andere Menschen in Bezug auf andere rein mentale Ereignisse
durchaus berechtigte
Schlussfolgerungen ziehen können  ob ich
irgendeine Absicht hatte, mich zu bewegen, und
was diese Absicht war, sie können
diese Schlussfolgerungen aus einer Studie meines
öffentlichen Verhaltens ziehen, einschließlich dessen, was ich sage, und
vielleicht eines Tages aus einer Studie meines Gehirns,
aber wie auch immer andere
über mich erfahren haben  Absichten, die ich auch verwenden
könnte Ich könnte mir einen Film über mein Verhalten ansehen
und mein Gehirn genau so gut wie anderswo studieren,
aber ich habe eine zusätzliche
Möglichkeit, die niemandem zur Verfügung steht, um zu
wissen, ob ich eine Absicht hatte und
was diese Absicht eigentlich war
die Absicht erfahren, und
notwendigerweise kann niemand sonst
meine Absicht erfahren, denn eine Person,
die eine Absicht erfährt, ist eine Person
, die die Absicht hat  Reine mentale Ereignisse
umfassen neben bewussten Ereignissen das, was
ich kontinuierliche mentale Zustände nenne, d. h.
Ereignisse wie Überzeugungen und Wünsche, die
auftreten können, während sich das Subjekt ihrer nicht
bewusst ist, derer es
sich aber bewusst werden kann, indem es sich fragt,
was es glaubt oder  Wünsche zu erkennen oder sich ihrer
bewusst zu sein, wenn sie plant
, sie in sich zu berücksichtigen
, sind reine mentale Ereignisse, denn
während das Subjekt alle Möglichkeiten nutzen kann, die
anderen zur Verfügung stehen, um herauszufinden, was
es glaubt oder wünscht, hat es heutzutage eine Möglichkeit, es zu
entdecken  was
für andere nicht verfügbar ist, ok, das ist
also meine Definition von Begriffen. Unsere
gewöhnliche Lebenserfahrung scheint
uns sehr stark zu zeigen, dass es Absichten gibt, die
oft dazu führen, dass unsere
Körperbewegungen zuerst berücksichtigt werden, und Absichten,
die möglicherweise erfolgreich sind oder nicht,
um die Wirkung zu erzielen  Beabsichtigte Wirkung
Nehmen wir zum Beispiel an, ich versuche, ein Gewicht zu heben,
es gelingt mir vielleicht nicht,
das Gewicht zu heben, aber wenn es mir gelingt
, scheint es mir st  Im Grunde genommen war
es meine Absicht,
das Gewicht zu heben, und da das Heben
des Gewichts eine absichtliche Handlung war
, scheint es mir stark, dass
dies der Versuch ist, etwas zu tun, das nur
erleichtert ist, das zu tun, was man glaubt  Dadurch wird
das Auftreten dessen
, was ich zu tun versuche, wahrscheinlicher. Das
Gewicht wird nicht steigen, es sei denn,
ich versuche es zu heben, je mehr ich versuche, desto
höher wird es steigen
das Gewicht heben, das meine Absicht verursacht
, ich warf meine Absicht, das heißt,
verursacht, es gibt ein Kontinuum von
Aktionen zwischen solchen Aktionen, die
ich, in denen ich kurze
Zeit versuchen muss, um die beabsichtigte
Wirkung zu erzielen, und  diese körperlichen Handlungen, die
für die meisten von uns so einfach durchzuführen sind
und die so kurze Zeit in Anspruch nehmen, dass wir uns
selten einer Zeit bewusst sind
, in der wir versuchen, die Wirkung hervorzurufen, und
dies noch nicht geschafft hat, aber
es gibt eindeutig eine  Unterschied zw  Wenn ich
meinen Arm absichtlich hebe und mein Arm sich
nur auf eine von mir unbeabsichtigte Weise erhebt
, scheint mir dieser Unterschied darin zu
bestehen, dass ich meinen Arm absichtlich bewege,
was sehen kann,
dass ich die Absicht habe, den Arm zu bewegen,
was die Bewegung des Arms verursacht, also
das ist das  So wie es uns scheint, ist es ein
grundlegendes epistemisches Prinzip, das
ich das Prinzip der Leichtgläubigkeit nenne. Es
wird von anderen Leuten manchmal
phänomenaler Konservatismus oder epistemischer
Konservatismus
genannt  Daher sind wir berechtigt
zu glauben, dass es vernünftig ist,
zu glauben, dass es wahrscheinlich so ist, abgesehen von Gegenbeweisen, dass es
defätistisch ist, wenn es mir scheint, dass
ich einen Baum sehe, dann sehe ich wahrscheinlich
einen Baum, wenn es mir scheint, dass ich  Wenn
ich Sie sprechen höre, höre ich Sie wahrscheinlich
all dies in
Ermangelung von Beweisen, dass ich einer Illusion unterworfen bin,
wenn wir uns nicht auf
unser Offensichtliches verlassen könnten  Wenn wir die Welt auf
diese Weise erfahren, auch wenn wir sie vielleicht durch erneutes
Hinsehen oder
längeres Zuhören überprüft haben, dann könnten wir überhaupt keine wirkliche
Kenntnis der Welt haben, da
unsere Erfahrung uns so stark zu sagen scheint,
dass unsere Absichten unsere
körperlichen bewirken  Bewegungen ist es in Ermangelung von
Gegenbeweisen sehr wahrscheinlich, dass sie es
tun. Die Wissenschaft hat uns das Gesetz gezeigt, dass unsere
Körperbewegungen direkter durch Gehirnereignisse verursacht werden, die
die
Abfolgen von Ereignissen in unseren Nerven
auslösen, die die Flaschenbewegungen verursachen, so dass es
sehr wahrscheinlich ist, dass  Unsere Absichten verursachen
die körperlichen Bewegungen, indem sie die Gehirnereignisse verursachen, die körperliche Bewegungen verursachen,
und so dass unsere mentalen Ereignisse
oft physische Ereignisse verursachen, so sehr für
eine Elternerfahrung, aber die Doktrin des
Zitierens des kausalen Verschlusses des physischen
Krugs, zusammengefasst von CCP, ist diese Doktrin
Die Doktrin, dass physische Ereignisse
nur durch physische Ereignisse verursacht werden,
folgt aus der KPCh,
dass solche Ansichten des gesunden Menschenverstandes wie die, die ich habe, kommen
e zu diesem Gebäude, weil ich die
Absicht hatte, dies zu tun, und die Absicht
verursachte, dass meine Beinbewegungen, die mich hierher brachten,
falsch sind. Nun ist es logisch
möglich, dass solche vernünftigen
Überzeugungen einfach Illusionen sind, aber angesichts meiner
vorherigen Argumentation wären
substanzielle Beweise erforderlich  das ist ein substanzieller
Gegenbeweis zu dem, was stark zu sein scheint
, um zu zeigen, dass es sich um
Illusionen handelt und dass CCP wahrscheinlich
wahr ist. CCP ist eine empirische Doktrin darüber,
welche Arten von Ereignissen welche anderen
Arten von Ereignissen verursachen, und daher erfordert ein gerechtfertigter
Glaube an CCP  ein gerechtfertigter
Glaube an irgendeine wissenschaftliche Theorie, die
es in diesem Aufsatz beinhaltet Ich behaupte, dass
die erkenntnistheoretische These, dass niemand
für die Armen argumentieren könnte, die
erkenntnistheoretische These, dass niemand
jemals gerechtfertigt sein könnte, irgendeiner
Theorie zu glauben, die KPCh und deren
Behauptungen beinhaltet  Jüngste neurowissenschaftliche Arbeiten
zur Erstellung dieser Rechtfertigung sind
nicht nur falsch, die
aufgrund dessen, was sie ausmachen, unmöglich wahr sein können  Ein
berechtigter Glaube an eine wissenschaftliche
Theorie Ein berechtigter Glaube an eine wissenschaftliche
Theorie erfordert einen berechtigten Glauben, dass
sie erfolgreiche Vorhersagen macht, und das
bedeutet sowohl den berechtigten Glauben, dass sie
bestimmte Ereignisse vorhersagt, als auch einen
berechtigten Glauben, dass diese Ereignisse
in dieser Arbeit aufgetreten sind  argumentieren,
dass mindestens eine dieser beiden
begründeten Überzeugungen der Theorie der gerechtfertigten Überzeugungen
bestimmte Ereignisse vorhersagt und die
berechtigte Überzeugung in Venedig stattgefunden hat,
werde ich argumentieren, dass mindestens eine
dieser gerechtfertigten Überzeugungen nicht zu haben wäre,
wenn die KPCh wahr wäre, daher ist die KPCh in  ein
entscheidendes Gefühl selbstzerstörerisch, wenn es
wahr wäre, könnten wir nicht gerechtfertigt sein, es zu
glauben, wie kann also jemand
berechtigterweise glauben,
dass eine wissenschaftliche Theorie
bestimmte Ereignisse vorhersagt, die Wissenschaftler auf diesem
relevanten Gebiet errechnet haben, dass
sie diese Vorhersagen macht, und wenn a
Die Wissenschaftlerin kann alle Berechnungen
auf einmal in ihrem Kopf behalten, es wird für
sie eine Befreiung der Vernunft sein, die unsere
Priorität ist  Wenn die Theorie diese Vorhersagen macht, werden die
meisten Experten auf diesem Gebiet leider für jede wissenschaftliche Theorie von beliebiger Komplexität
nicht in der Lage sein,
alle relevanten Berechnungen gleichzeitig im Kopf zu behalten
, selbst wenn die Wissenschaftlerin
den Text ihrer Berechnungen durchliest,
hängt sie von ihr ab  Erinnerung gegen Ende
der Berechnung für ihren Glauben, dass die
anfänglichen Berechnungen später im Leben richtig waren,
alles, woran er sich vielleicht erinnern kann, ist, dass
es zu einem früheren Zeitpunkt weh zu tun schien, dass
die Theorie diese Vorhersagen machte, dass
sie möglicherweise ein Tagebuch hat, in dem sie
dies aufzeichnete  was sozusagen
ihr Zeugnis darüber gegenüber sich selbst und
anderen Nichtwissenschaftlern und Wissenschaftlern sein wird, die
weniger zentral auf dem Gebiet sind, wird von
den Aussagen derjenigen abhängen, die sie
als Experten betrachten, dass sie diese
Berechnungen angestellt haben, also was jemanden
glauben lässt, dass die Theorie vorhersagt  Bestimmte
Ereignisse begründen einen berechtigten Glauben,
wenn man aus eigener Erfahrung erfahren kann
, dass die
Berechnungen richtig sind  oder Erinnerung an
solche Berechnungen in der Vergangenheit oder
Aussagen von sich selbst oder anderen, dass
sie bestimmte Sammelberechnungen durchgeführt haben
, oder vielmehr, da all
diese Quellen irreführend sein können, was
offensichtliche Erfahrungen, scheinbare Erinnerungen und
offensichtliche Zeugnisse sind, die unseren
berechtigten Glauben an die Theorie liefern
Wahre Vorhersagen, die in Abwesenheit von Gegenbeweisen gerechtfertigt sind, werden
oft als
defätistisch bezeichnet, und wie kann jemand einen
berechtigten Glauben haben, dass die
vorhergesagten Ereignisse tatsächlich eingetreten sind? Sie werden
normalerweise von den Beweisen
derselben drei Quellen abhängen. Bestimmte Beobachter werden
wir anscheinend im weitesten Sinne
diese Ereignisse erleben, das heißt, wenn es
sich um physische Ereignisse handelt, werden sie sie
wahrnehmen, oder wenn es sich um bewusste Ereignisse
handelt, werden sie sie später in einem engeren Sinne erleben.
Die Beobachter können sich anscheinend
daran erinnern, die Ereignisse erlebt zu haben,
und andere werden sich auf die offensichtlichen
Aussagen von Beobachtern über diese verlassen
Ereignisse oder die Beobachter können von
ihrer eigenen scheinbaren Schrift abhängen
Alternativ kann ein
Gläubiger eine begründete Überzeugung haben, dass die
vorhergesagten Ereignisse eingetreten sind, weil es eine
deduktive oder wahrscheinlichkeitstheoretische Folge
einer anderen gerechtfertigten
Theorie ist, von der Blake glaubte, dass sie es taten, aber in
diesem Fall würde eine berechtigte Überzeugung von dieser
anderen Theorie selbst abhängen  die
Beweise der gleichen drei Quellen, wenn
wir glauben, dass unsere scheinbare
Erfahrung eine reale Erfahrung ist, da
wir sicher sind, dass sie nach dem Prinzip der Leichtgläubigkeit normalerweise
gerechtfertigt sind, in Ermangelung von
Gegenbeweisen glauben wir ihnen, weil
wir glauben, dass sie durch sie verursacht wurden  die
offensichtlich erlebten Ereignisse Sie
glauben, dass Ihre scheinbare Erfahrung,
einen fernen Stern durch ein
Teleskop zu beobachten, eine reale Erfahrung ist und sagt,
dass es dort wirklich einen Stern gibt, weil
Sie glauben, dass Ihre scheinbare
Erfahrung durch den Stern verursacht wurde, der
Licht aussendet, das auf Ihre
Augen trifft und  verursacht die offensichtliche
Erfahrung davon, wenn Sie zu glauben kamen, dass Ihr
Erscheinen  Wenn die Erfahrung nicht durch eine
Fehlfunktion des Teleskops verursacht wurde und
keinen anderen Grund hatte zu glauben, dass der
Stern da war, würden Sie aufhören zu
glauben, dass der Stern da war. Wenn also
Ihre scheinbare Erfahrung eine reale
Erfahrung ist, dann verursacht ein physisches Ereignis
ein mentales Ereignis  und das
wird von CCP natürlich nicht ausgeschlossen, dass unsere
scheinbaren Erinnerungen an unsere Erfahrungen
selbst scheinbare Erfahrungen unserer
positiven Erfahrungen sind,
und so sind wir wiederum durch das Prinzip der
Leichtgläubigkeit berechtigt zu glauben,
dass diese Erfahrungen in der Vergangenheit
ohne Gegenbeweise stattfanden
wir glauben, dass wir glauben,
dass diese vergangenen Erfahrungen stattgefunden haben,
weil wir glauben, dass, wenn wir unseren
scheinbaren Erinnerungen glauben, das unsere Erinnerungen
an unsere vergangenen Erfahrungen
sind
Erfahrungen weniger als ein paar Minuten
früher kann es sein, dass die vergangene
Erfahrung den PR verursacht  Es ist eine direkte Erinnerung
daran, das heißt, ohne es
durch ein anderes Ereignis zu verursachen,
das die Erinnerung verursacht, aber wir wissen gut, und die
Neurowissenschaft hat uns auch gezeigt, dass
im Fall von Erinnerungen an Ereignisse, die mehr als
ein paar Minuten zurückliegen, die Verursachung
indirekt ist, das heißt die  vergangene Erfahrungen
verursachen ein Gehirnereignis, eine Spur im
Gehirn, die später die Erinnerung
daran verursacht, und daher hängt unser Vertrauen auf die scheinbare
Erinnerung für unser Wissen über vergangene Ereignisse
von der Annahme ab, dass ein mentales Ereignis,
eine vergangene Erfahrung, ein physisches
Ereignis verursacht, das Gehirnereignis, das in  wiederum
unser Gedächtnis erzwingt, folgt aus
dem Prinzip der Leichtgläubigkeit auch, wenn es
uns so vorkommt, als würde uns jemand
etwas mündlich oder schriftlich
mitteilen, so sind wir berechtigt zu glauben, dass
er uns das mitteilt, mangels
Gegenbeweise gehen wir von seiner
Absicht aus  uns mitzuteilen, woran sie sich
anscheinend erinnern, hat dazu geführt, dass die Worte, die
über die Erfahrung berichten, aus
ihrem Mund kommen oder in ihren Computer getippt werden,
wenn wir c  Ich kann glauben, dass die
Worte, die aus dem Mund einer Person
kamen, aus ihrem Mund herauskamen, weil sie
an Fluidaphasie leiden, einer
Krankheit, die Ströme unbeabsichtigter Worte hervorruft, die
aus
jemandes Mund kommen, wenn wir glauben, dass die
Worte, wenn wir
das glauben  Die Worte, die aus
dem Mund einer Person kamen, kamen aus
diesem Grund nur unbeabsichtigt heraus. Gut,
dass die Finger dieser Person, die Tasten auf
der Computertastatur drücken, von einem Neurowissenschaftler verursacht wurden
, der die neuronalen
Impulse an ihren Fingern kontrollierte. Wir würden
diesem Zeugnis nicht mehr das Offensichtliche glauben
Zeugenaussage wäre keine
echte Zeugenaussage, wir glauben
, dass die Zeugenaussage eines Elternteils mich glauben ließ, dass der
Zeuge die Absicht hatte, dass das Wort
aus seinem Mund kommen sollte, und dass diese
Absicht dazu geführt hat, dass die Worte
aus seinem Mund kamen, und wenn wir auch
glauben  das offensichtliche Zeugnis einer Person, ein
Ereignis in der Vergangenheit erlebt zu haben,
nehmen wir an, dass ihre vergangene Erfahrung sie
verursacht hat  Die scheinbare Erinnerung daran wiederum ist
eine mentale bis physische Verursachung, und
wenn man sich auf die Aussage eines Elternteils zu einem vergangenen
Ereignis verlässt, muss man sich auf zwei getrennte
Prozesse der mentalen bis physischen Verursachung verlassen,
die in dem Sinne verursacht werden, dass sie
ein notwendiger Teil der Gesamtursache sind
das physische Ereignis. Wenn wir uns also auf
[Musik]
Elternerinnerung
verlassen, verlassen wir uns auf das Auftreten eines
mentalen oder physischen Ereignisses, wenn wir uns auf das Eintreten eines mentalen oder physischen Ereignisses verlassen, und wenn wir uns
auf das Zeugnis einer Person über ihre
Erfahrung eines vergangenen Ereignisses verlassen  sich
nicht auf zwei Prozesse geistiger und
körperlicher Verursachung verlassen, einen in ihnen und einen
in ihnen, der ihre gegenwärtige Erinnerung
verursacht, und einen in ihnen, der bewirkt, dass ihre Worte
aus ihrem Mund kommen, ein
Wissenschaftler seine offensichtlichen Beobachtungen,
Erfahrungen und Berechnungen zumindest als wahrscheinlich
richtig ansieht  Wenn er
genau hingesehen und in Ermangelung
gegenteiliger Beweise überprüft wurde, beruhen beispielsweise fast alle wissenschaftlichen
Erkenntnisse
auf dem Elterngedächtnis
der Ergebnisse von Experimenten oder
Berechnungen erst am
nächsten Tag niedergeschrieben, und für die gesamte Wissenschaft verlassen wir uns
die meiste Zeit auf die offensichtlichen
schriftlichen und mündlichen Aussagen von
Beobachtern, die bestimmte
Beobachtungen gemacht oder bestimmte Erfahrungen gemacht haben,
und von Theoretikern, die
bestimmte Berechnungen durchgeführt haben und  Die breitere
Öffentlichkeit verlässt sich
sowohl
hinsichtlich ihrer Berechnungen als auch hinsichtlich ihrer
Beobachtungen vollständig auf die offensichtlichen Aussagen von Wissenschaftlern. Ein einsamer Wissenschaftler
wäre berechtigt, seinen scheinbaren Wahrnehmungen zu glauben,
während er sie tatsächlich
wahrnahm, ohne anzunehmen, dass
es eine geistige oder körperliche
Ursache gab, aber nein  man wäre berechtigt
, einer großen wissenschaftlichen
Theorie zu glauben, ohne viele Beweise
über das Auftreten von Ereignissen zu
verschiedenen Zeiten und an verschiedenen Orten zu haben und
seine Berechnungen von anderen Wissenschaftlern bestätigen zu lassen
, und so scheint es, dass
wir keine signifikante
Rechtfertigung für den Glauben haben können  in jeder
wissenschaftlichen Theorie ohne rel  Auf
offensichtliche Erinnerungen und offensichtliche Zeugnisse
zu vertrauen und sich daher nicht auf Prozesse zu verlassen,
die darin bestehen, dass mentale Ereignisse
physische Ereignisse verursachen, daher scheint es, dass
niemand jemals berechtigt wäre,
CCP zu glauben, da die Rechtfertigung
darin bestehen würde, an das
Auftreten von Prozessen zu glauben, die es wären
von CCP selbst ausgeschlossen, dennoch haben
Wissenschaftler versucht, PC CCP zu etablieren,
und es gibt zwei verschiedene Wege,
auf denen sie dies versucht haben
oder zumindest versuchen könnten,
und der erste Weg besteht darin, zu versuchen zu zeigen,
dass sie niemals welche macht  Unterschied
zum Muster späterer physischer Ereignisse,
ob einige mentale Ereignisse auftreten, und
der naheliegende Weg, dies anzugehen
, wäre zu zeigen, dass der plausibelste
Kandidat für mentale Ereignisse, die einen
solchen Unterschied machen, dass unsere Absichten
niemals
Bezug auf unsere Gehirnereignisse nehmen  und dies ist,
wie viele von Ihnen wissen werden, das, was ein
kürzlich durchgeführtes neurowissenschaftliches
Forschungsprogramm versucht hat, das Programm i  Initiiert
durch die Arbeit von Benjamin Libet in den
1980er Jahren wurden diese Ergebnisse
von vielen Wissenschaftlern interpretiert
und zeigen, dass bewusste Ereignisse und damit
mentale Ereignisse im Allgemeinen in meinem Sinne
niemals Gehirnereignisse verursachen, und in den
ursprünglichen und einflussreichsten Labette-
Experimenten wurden Versuchspersonen unterbrochen,
um sich zu bewegen  zu einem Zeitpunkt ihrer
Wahl
innerhalb eines kurzen festgelegten Zeitraums,
beispielsweise eines Zeitraums von 20 Sekunden,
beobachteten die Probanden eine sehr schnelle Uhr und
gaben anschließend die genaue Zeit an, zu
der sie ihre Absicht formten, ihre Hand zu bewegen.
sie gaben die Absicht
an, ihre Hand zu bewegen  Da das Experiment
durchschnittlich 200 Millisekunden vor dem Zeitpunkt stattfand,
an dem das Experiment den
Beginn der Aktivität in den Muskeln der Testperson aufgezeichnet hat, die
die Handbewegung einleiten,
ist dies meiner Meinung nach auf Ihrem Handout, wenn Sie
die Details von
Experimenten anderer Art, die Libet behauptete, nicht verfolgt haben
Probanden geben an, dass die Zeit der
Empfindungen 50 Millisekunden vor der
Zeit des br auftrat  ain Ereignisse, die sie veranlassten
, die ihn zu der Annahme veranlassten, dass die
Probanden die Zeit aller
bewussten Ereignisse um 50 Millisekunden falsch eingeschätzt hatten, und
so kam er zu dem Schluss, dass ihre Absicht
im Durchschnitt 150 Millisekunden
vor der Muskelaktivierung stattfand, aber
Elektroden, die auf der Kopfhaut der Probanden platziert
wurden, wurden bei jeder Hand aufgezeichnet  Bewegung
eine Anhäufung von elektrischem
Potential namens Bereitschaftspotential RP, das
vermutlich durch das Auftreten einer
bestimmten Art von Gehirnereignis verursacht wurde, das
im Durchschnitt 500 und 50
Millisekunden vor der Muskelaktivität
und damit 400 Millisekunden vor ihren
Strömen
der letzten 30 auftrat  Jahren sehr
beträchtliche Fortschritte beim Verständnis
der neuralen Grundlagen absichtlicher Handlungen
gemacht haben, die durch neue Techniken ermöglicht wurden, mit
denen Neurowissenschaftler jetzt
viel genauer als durch Messungen des
elektrischen Potentials auf der Kopfhaut viel genauer identifizieren können
, welche Bereiche des Gehirns in einer
bestimmten Anzahl aktiv sind  von Millisekunden
vor der Zeit  bei denen die Probanden behaupten, dass
sie eine Absicht bilden, und die
Ergebnisse dieser Arbeit scheinen
zunächst die Ansicht sehr zu stützen,
dass ein vorheriges Gehirnereignis der Art,
das RP hervorruft, eine notwendige
Bedingung ist, sie ist nicht unbedingt eine
ausreichende  Bedingung Es ist eine notwendige
Bedingung für das Auftreten einer einfachen
absichtlichen Körperbewegung der Art,
die von livet untersucht wurde. Wenn also die Berichte der Versuchspersonen
überhaupt korrekt sind, gibt es einen
Erfolg dieser Abfolge von Ereignissen, und
das wird im Diagramm am
Ende Ihres Handzettels gezeigt  Abfolge von
Ereignissen ein Gehirnereignis v1, gefolgt von einem
bewussten Ereignis, der Absicht,
dargestellt durch m1 im Diagramm auf dem
Handout, und auch gefolgt von anderen Gehirnereignissen
, dargestellt durch b2 und b3, und dann
später als m1 ein Gehirnereignis, dargestellt
durch b4, das direkt verursacht
Muskelaktivität und damit die Bewegung und viele
Neurowissenschaftler haben aus dieser
Art von Beweisen argumentiert, um zu dem
außergewöhnlichen Schluss der Verlängerung zu gelangen
verursacht nicht die Bewegung. Eine Gruppe von
Wissenschaftlern, Neurowissenschaftler, schloss zum
Beispiel aus libbets-Daten, dass libbets-
Daten, ich zitiere Vertrag, dies ist ein
Zitat, das der naiven Ansicht des freien Willens widerspricht,
dass bewusste Absicht eine Handlung
verursacht
korreliert mit dem vorausgehenden Action-
Auto und
korreliert mit der Aktion kommt vor
aller Intention bewusste Intention
, das heißt diese Wissenschaftler argumentierten,
weil es ein Ereignis RP gab, das
mit der Körperbewegung korrelierte und
man damit nichts zu tun haben konnte
natürlich folgt das überhaupt nicht,
weil B eins verursachen könnte, rpb1 könnte
M eins verursachen und M eins könnte die
Körperbewegung verursachen, also war diese spezielle
Schlussfolgerung eindeutig falsch, aber
nichtsdestotrotz und die natürlichste
Erklärung der Daten wäre
offensichtlich, dass B 1  was auch unser P
verursachte m1 die Absicht hinter der
Absicht verursachte die körperliche Bewegung
Um zu zeigen, dass die Absicht nicht auch ein
notwendiger Teil der Ursache war, müssten Sie
zeigen, dass ein früheres Ereignis B 1
genau dieselbe Folge von Gehirnereignissen verursacht
, mit oder ohne Subjekte,
die die erforderliche Absicht haben, diese
Flaschenbewegung und das Lebec-Programm hervorzurufen
versucht bei weitem nicht, dies zu zeigen
, aber das Hauptproblem bei
Experimenten vom Grenztyp ist dasjenige, auf das ich
zuvor aufmerksam gemacht habe,
dass dieses Programm, um dies oder irgendetwas anderes zu zeigen,
auf die offensichtlichen Aussagen von Probanden angewiesen ist,
um Informationen über die
Zeit des zu erhalten  Das Auftreten ihrer mentalen Ereignisse
und damit alles über Typ
Experimente, die zeigen sollen, dass mentale Ereignisse
keine physischen Ereignisse verursachen, erfordern vom
Experimentator die Annahme, dass manchmal
mentale Ereignisse physische Ereignisse verursachen.
Solche Experimente könnten dazu dienen, zu zeigen,
dass bestimmte Arten von Körperbewegungen
zum Beispiel diese sind  In Freiheit untersuchte
Experimente, die wir
als von unseren Absichten geformt betrachtet haben könnten, sind in Wirklichkeit
keine  Sie werden nicht von unseren Absichten gebildet, aber sie
könnten nur zeigen, dass, wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass
andere Körperbewegungen wie die
Bewegungen unserer Lippen bei der Mitteilung unserer
Absichten von diesen Absichten gebildet werden,
derselbe allgemeine Einwand eindeutig
für jeden Versuch gilt, die KPCh zu etablieren,
der sich auf Beweise stützt  darüber, welche
mentalen Ereignisse auftreten, wenn wir nur
genügend Beweise bekommen könnten, um die
Theorie als wahr zu erweisen, indem wir uns auf die offensichtlichen
Aussagen anderer Menschen verlassen, und das
beinhaltet die Annahme, dass die Theorie
falsch ist, das ist eine Möglichkeit, zu
versuchen, die KPCh zu zeigen, dass sie versucht, diese mentale Tatsache zu zeigen  Wenn auf
halbem Weg mentale Ereignisse auftreten,
machen sie keinen Unterschied, aber
natürlich wären die angegebenen Gründe
selbstzerstörerisch, aber es gibt einen zweiten Weg,
auf dem es den Anschein haben könnte, dass Wissenschaftler
CCP etablieren könnten, und das ist auf der
Grundlage von  Beweise nur darüber, welche
physikalischen Ereignisse wann auftreten,
ohne sich auf Beweise darüber zu stützen, welche
mentalen Ereignisse stattfinden, könnten eine Win-Win-
Beobachtung von p  Physikalische
Ereignisse geben uns einen berechtigten
Glauben an eine sehr allgemeine
deterministische physikalische Theorie, aus
der folgt, dass jedes physikalische Ereignis ein
anderes physikalisches Ereignis als unmittelbar
vorausgehende notwendige und hinreichende Ursache hat, wenn
dies gezeigt werden könnte, würde folgen, dass
kein Ereignis das O Gehirnereignis ist  könnte ein
mentales Ereignis als notwendigen Teil seiner
Ursache haben, denn wenn eine deterministische physikalische
Theorie dieser Art wahr
wäre, wäre das physische Ereignis sowieso aufgetreten,
welche mentalen Ereignisse das
Subjekt auch gehabt hätte, es hätte keinen
Unterschied zu den Gehirnereignissen gemacht, angenommen,
dass Wissenschaftler das entdecken  Für jedes
physikalische Ereignis, wenn es in großen
Stichproben von vielen verschiedenen Arten von
physikalischen Ereignissen untersucht wird, einschließlich offensichtlicher
absichtlicher Körperbewegungen, gibt es
ein anderes unmittelbar vorhergehendes physikalisches
Ereignis II, von dem eine bestimmte deterministische
Theorie behauptet, dass es F als
unmittelbare Wirkung haben wird, was ein starker Beweis dafür zu sein scheint
dieser
Theorie und damit zugunsten der KPCh das
Problem jedoch  Er bleibt, dass unsere
Beweise darüber, welche physikalischen
Ereignisse wann in den
letzten Beispielen von Ereignissen auftreten, selbst
aus den Berichten von Wissenschaftlern über die
Ergebnisse ihrer Experimente stammen müssen, dh
aus den offensichtlichen Zeugnissen und
Erinnerungen von Wissenschaftlern darüber, was sie
behaupten, aber wir wahrgenommen zu haben  Wir haben gesehen,
aber wir sind nur dann berechtigt, uns auf
scheinbare Erinnerungen und Zeugenaussagen zu verlassen, wenn wir
berechtigt sind anzunehmen, dass vergangene
Beobachtungen Gehirnereignisse
verursachen, die gegenwärtige Erinnerungen hervorrufen, und die Absichten der Menschen dazu führen,
dass Worte aus
ihrem Mund kommen, also verlassen wir uns wieder auf die
Beweise von  die offensichtliche Erinnerung und das
Zeugnis von Wissenschaftlern über das, was sie
bereits beobachtet haben, scheint
die Falschheit von CCP zu preisen, aber es ist
möglich, diesen Einwand im
Fall des zweiten Versuchs
, CCP zu beweisen, zu vermeiden, indem wir unser Verständnis
von Erinnerung und unser Verständnis modifizieren  von
Zeugnissen in einer Weise, dass man sagen könnte,
dass wir uns an ein vergangenes physisches Ereignis erinnern,
ohne dass wir davon ausgehen  g dass die Erinnerung
das Erinnern an eine vergangene
Erfahrung dieses Ereignisses beinhaltet und dass wir sagen würden, dass wir
das Eintreten eines
vergangenen Ereignisses bezeugen, ohne anzunehmen, dass dies
das Bezeugen einer früheren
Erfahrung dieses Ereignisses beinhaltet, wir könnten zum Beispiel
Erinnerung einfach als Erinnerung verstehen
des Auftretens von Ereignissen und nicht nur von
Ereignissen, die nicht nur von Ereignissen, die
auftreten, Erfahrungen des Auftretens
von Ereignissen sind, könnte man sagen, dass sich ein Subjekt
an ein vergangenes physisches Ereignis erinnert,
weil diese Ereignisse Spuren in
seinem Gehirn hinterlassen, die in spätere Zeiten zurückreichen
die scheinbare Erinnerung an diese Ereignisse,
ohne dass eine mentale oder physische
Ursache beteiligt ist die Erinnerungsspur wird
im Gehirn einer Person durch das
Auftreten eines Ereignisses verursacht bewirken manchmal,
dass diese Person
später Einzelheiten dieses Ereignisses wahrnimmt, bei denen
sie nicht dabei war  zeitbewusst und so
scheint es nicht unserer natürlichen Verwendung
des Wortes erinnern
zu sagen, dass sie sich an diese Details erinnerten,
damit Sie es könnten  Man kann sagen, dass man sich an
ein Ereignis erinnert, einfach weil das Ereignis
eine Spur in Ihrem Gehirn hinterlassen hat,
die zu der Zeit vielleicht nicht bewusst
war, aber dennoch später
eine offensichtliche Erinnerung daran hervorbrach, nicht
an Ihre Erfahrung davon, und das
wäre  genug, um zu zeigen, dass das physische
Ereignis auf dieser Strecke stattfand,
um sogar Erinnerungen zu verstehen
, die nicht allzu unnatürlich erscheinen
, wenn das Wort „Erinnerung“ verwendet wird, und in diesem Fall wäre die
einzige Annahme, dass ein
vergangenes Ereignis einen gegenwärtigen Glauben verursacht hat, dass
es passiert ist, und das tut es
keine psychische oder physische Kausalität beinhalten und wir
konnten unser Verständnis von
Zeugenaussagen sehr erweitern. Wir hatten
gelernt, dass Zeugenaussagen lediglich auf die öffentliche Äußerung von Sätzen hinauslaufen, in denen berichtet wird, dass ein Ereignis eingetreten ist oder dass ein Sturm durch eine Kette
von Ereignissen verursacht wurde  Attar
selbst verursacht durch das gemeldete Ereignis eine
Kette, die keine
bewussten Ereignisse beinhalten muss, in diesem Fall
würde der Mann die Aussage nicht prüfen  y dass
der Zeuge die Ereignisse beobachtet,
aber nur bezeugt hatte, dass die Ereignisse stattgefunden hatten
, sodass die Augen von jemandem
Lichtstrahlen von physischen Ereignissen empfangen konnten
und weil diese physischen
Ereignisse Gehirnereignisse bei dieser Person verursachten, konnte die Person
sie anschließend melden, ohne
dass diese Kausalkette durch irgendwelche weiterging
bewusste Ereignisse überhaupt durch die
Person, die sich ihrer überhaupt bewusst ist,
das Ereignis der Worte
nur aus seinem Mund kommen würde, er wäre
nicht er, nicht weil er sie beabsichtigte, sondern
weil ein Gehirnereignis sie veranlasste,
aus seinem Mund zu kommen  Das Gehirnereignis
wird durch die Ereignisse verursacht, die anscheinend so
bezeugt werden, und auf diese Weise könnten wir
unser gerrantes Verständnis von
Erinnerung und Zeugnis wirklich erweitern, um von
dem Problem wegzukommen, dass Wissenschaftler anscheinend Erinnerung und Zeugnis brauchen, um
jemals
stärker oder natürlicher zu sein
berechtigt, an ihren Theorien festzuhalten, und
das würde eine psychische bis physische
Verursachung beinhalten, selbst wenn Sie sich anstrengen  Wenn Sie
diese Ich bin nur Ihr
Verständnis von Erinnerung und Zeugnis auf
diese Weise ausdehnen, wird Ihnen vielleicht ein
Weg aufgezeigt, auf dem Wissenschaftler kommen können, um
zu lernen, und andere Menschen kommen können, um etwas
über das Auftreten bestimmter physikalischer
Ereignisse zu erfahren, die tatsächlich vorhergesagt wurden  eine
physikalische Theorie, aber es gibt eine weitere
und meines Erachtens unüberwindbare Schwierigkeit
anzunehmen, dass wir jemals einen begründeten Glauben haben könnten,
dass eine deterministische
physikalische Theorie wahre Vorhersagen
über die Beziehungen zwischen physikalischen
Ereignissen liefert, und das ist, dass wir auch
nicht nur einen begründeten brauchen würden  Glaube, dass
bestimmte Beziehungen zwischen physikalischen
Ereignissen stattgefunden haben, aber auch ein berechtigter
Glaube, dass diese Beziehungen
von dieser deterministischen Theorie vorhergesagt wurden.
Denken Sie daran, dass Sie zwei Arten von
Überzeugungen brauchen, um einer Theorie zu glauben, Sie müssen
glauben, dass bestimmte physikalische Ereignisse
stattgefunden haben, und Sie müssen das glauben
Diese Theorie sagt diese physischen
Ereignisse voraus und es ist die zweite,
die das in mein m verursacht  Ind unüberwindliche
Schwierigkeiten für ccp Jeder, der nicht
für sich selbst berechnet hat, was diese Theorie
über die Beziehungen zwischen physikalischen Ereignissen vorhergesagt hat,
muss sich auf die
Beweise verlassen, die durch die offensichtlichen
Aussagen von Wissenschaftlern geliefert werden, die
dies berechnet haben, und ihre Aussage, dass
sie gesehen hatten, dass es ein Bewusstsein hatte
glauben, dass die Theorie dies
vorhergesagt hat, das heißt, sie bräuchten
Beweise für die bewussten Ereignisse von
Wissenschaftlern, nicht nur, dass ihre
physischen Ereignisse stattgefunden haben, sondern der
Wissenschaftler hat gesehen, dass die Theorie
diese Ereignisse vorhergesagt hat, und das wäre ein
Beweis für ihre
bewussten Ereignisse, aber wenn die
Wenn die deterministische Fiat-Physiktheorie
wahr wäre, könnten die Wissenschaftler nicht dazu
veranlasst worden sein, dieses Zeugnis abzugeben, weil
sie sagen wollten, was sie
über das sagten, was die Theorie vorhersagte, weil
dies eine geistige bis körperliche Verursachung wäre,
und ebenso aus dem gleichen
Grund, auf den sich kein Wissenschaftler verlassen könnte  sein
eigenes Zeugnis für sich selbst, aufgezeichnet in einem
Tagebuch, das er hatte  zuvor
die Folgen der deterministischen
Theorie berechnet, und ein Wissenschaftler könnte sich nicht
auf seine eigene scheinbare Erinnerung verlassen
, diese Folgen für
einen Gimp
berechnet zu haben, der seine früheren Erfahrungen mit seinen Berechnungen einbeziehen würde, die
das Gehirnereignis verursachten, das sein Gedächtnis verursachte,
nur wenn ein Wissenschaftler dies könnte  Wenn er
auf einmal all seine Berechnungen im Kopf hat,
aus denen anscheinend folgte, dass
die deterministische Theorie
bestimmte Ereignisse vorhersagte, könnte er einen berechtigten
Glauben haben, dass die Theorie erfolgreiche
Vorhersagen machte, und so einen berechtigten Glauben an
CCP haben, das die meisten wissenschaftlichen Theorien und die
meisten Wissenschaftler dies sind
Der entscheidende Unterschied zwischen dem
berechtigten Glauben, dass bestimmte physikalische
Ereignisse stattgefunden haben, und dem berechtigten
Glauben, dass eine bestimmte Theorie
diese Ereignisse vorhergesagt hat, ist höchst unwahrscheinlich, dass wir für letzteres
Beweise brauchen, nicht nur für das
Auftreten physikalischer Ereignisse, sondern
Beweise für deren Strömungen  bewusste
Ereignisse, das heißt, wenn wir oder jemand el  Wenn wir
sicher sind, dass die
Berechnungen wahr sind und Dourdan die vatic
Beweise haben, müssen wir oder sie sich auf einen
Prozess einer vergangenen Erfahrung verlassen, der eine
gegenwärtige Erinnerung an diese exponierte
Erfahrung verursacht, was darin besteht, dass ein
Gehirnzustand verursacht wird, der die gegenwärtige
Erinnerung verursacht, oder und  /oder des Wissenschaftlers
, der seine Berechnungen berichtet, die wir
selbst verstehen könnten,
wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass seine Absicht,
diese Berechnungen zu melden, dazu führte, dass die
Worte aus seinem Mund kamen, also
begann ich mit einigen Definitionen
glauben sollte, dass die
Dinge so sind, wie sie in Ermangelung von Gegenbeweisen zu sein scheinen, scheint
mir der Fall zu sein, dass unsere Absichten
unsere Körperbewegungen verursachen und dass CCP
falsch sein muss, aber vielleicht gibt es das
nur in Ermangelung von Gegenbeweisen
und  Könnte es Gegenbeweise geben? Ich
brachte ein allgemeines Argument vor, dass
es keine Gegenbeweise geben könne, da alle
Beweise von offensichtlichen Erfahrungen abhingen
Erinnerung und Zeugenaussage und die
Abhängigkeit von kausalen Prozessen,
die mentale Ereignisse beinhalteten, die physische Ereignisse verursachten
, und dann ging ich weiter, um
zwei Möglichkeiten zu betrachten, auf denen Wissenschaftler
ihre Schlussfolgerung zu beweisen versuchten oder versuchen könnten,
erstens, indem sie zeigten, dass
bestimmte physische Prozesse stattfanden  und
dass die gleichen Prozesse
ohne die Absicht des Auftretens
eines mentalen Ereignisses ablaufen würden, und ich teile das, und dass ein
Beispiel dafür Libet-
Experimente waren, aber ich zeigte, dass sie
offensichtlich fehlschlugen, weil Sie nichts
über das Auftreten des Mentalen lernen konnten  Ereignis,
ohne sich auf die Prozesse zu verlassen,
die gegen die KPCh verstoßen würden, aber dann fuhr ich fort
, dass wir nicht lernen könnten,
was in der physischen Welt passiert,
ohne uns auf das Wissen über die
mentalen Ereignisse zu verlassen, und oberflächlich nein,
weil wir uns auf Wissenschaftler verlassen würden
Erinnerungen und Zeugnisse dieser Ereignisse,
um etwas darüber zu erfahren, aber ich schlug vor, dass
wir vielleicht die Worte ausdehnen könnten
unser Verständnis von Erinnerung
und Zeugnis so zu erinnern, dass
wir uns an ein vergangenes physikalisches Ereignis erinnern können
, ohne dass dieser Prozess abläuft,
ohne dass es
bei unserem Erwerb der Erinnerung eine geistige oder körperliche Ursache gibt,
und ebenso mit
Zeugnis, aber ich habe das sogar gesagt  Wenn wir
dies meiner Meinung nach etwas illegitim tun, denke ich
, etwas illegitim,
dennoch könnte die Theorie selbst aufgestellt
werden, wenn festgestellt werden könnte,
dass die Theorie diese bestimmten Ereignisse vorhergesagt hat,
und wir können dies nur
wissen, wenn wir uns nicht nur auf die
bewussten Ereignisse verlassen  ein physisches
Ereignis, sondern das bewusste Ereignis von
Wissenschaftlern, das unser Wissen darüber verursacht,
und das beinhaltet eine Verletzung der KPCh,
so dass die KPCh niemals etabliert werden konnte, das
ist meine These